[Music]
this is the only school most of these
children have ever known
a mobile school called panpath travels
from village to village in kandahar
province in southern afghanistan
there are no classrooms or desks but
there is a will to learn
it is very nice here and i'm learning a
lot i just wish that the schools for my
eldest sister cousins and other older
girls would open again
the makeshift classroom is carried on a
motorbike with a tv set and books with
subjects taught by eight volunteers
schools are scarce in these remote areas
and across afghanistan around three and
a half million children mostly girls
don't go to school
[Music]
if they want long lasting peace and
stability in afghanistan and if the
country is to stand alongside the rest
of the world all the attention should be
given to education especially in the
areas where there have been no schools
in the last 20 years
back in march the taliban ordered
schools for girls above the sixth grade
to close
for girls living in remote areas the
first challenge is not having access to
a school
then as they get older not being allowed
to attend one
these villagers support the project but
convincing a deeply conservative society
to allow their daughters to study in
school isn't always welcomed but there
are differing voices
we are very happy that boys and girls
are able to study here i think the
government must reopen all schools until
the 12th grade for both boys and girls
it's their islamic right and it should
be given to them
the project has its limits but the
founder hopes it will play a role
however small and helping the next
generation
katia lopez oban al jazeera